>>Ilya Grogorik: Hi everyone. My name is Ilya
Grigorik. I'm a developer advocate with the
make the web fast team at Google. One of the
projects we have is the PageSpeed family of
products that can help you both automate web
performance and also give you insights about
what are the kinds of things you can do to
improve the performance of your applications.
So first of all, why do we need this? Why
does web performance matter? It is more to
start at the beginning, motivate the use case.
First of all, as you saw during the keynote.
The web of today, the things we are building
on the web are much more ambitious and more
powerful and more complex, in many ways, and
speed is a feature. We are increasingly hearing
this from our partners that are connecting
performance to bottom line things like revenue
and engagement -- user engagement and other
things. This is not just something that we
feel is getting more complex. In fact, we
can show this. There's a great project called
HP archive which crawls the web and gathers
statistics about how the web is constructed
and how it is changing over time. And what
this graph shows you very clearly is that
the complexity of our pages, the amount of
HTML, JavaScript, the markup we are putting
on our pages is growing very, very fast. If
anything, if you look at this number here,
an average page on the web today is over one
megabyte in size for desktop size and 700
kilobytes in mobile, which is very large.
Most of that is actually images. So if nothing
else, this is a real interesting insight to
say you should optimize your images or 60%
of all the bytes are images. That's the first
constant. The web is getting -- we are building
more ambitious applications and they are more
complex. The other interesting thing is that
despite the ever-increasing speed of and demand
from users for performance and other things,
an accelerating pace of life, or so it seems,
there are some pretty good constants. There's
good research that shows in order to feel
instant, an interaction needs to be acknowledged
back to the user within basically a couple
hundred milliseconds. If you respond within
200 milliseconds, it feels nearly instant.
Then there is that kind of gray zone around
one second where the user is still engaged
in the task when they click the button but
after you cross that one-second threshold,
you lose the context as a user. So all of
the sudden your context switch, oh, yeah,
I have to send an email to Bob, and follow
up with Jamie. Before you know it, you lost
track of your user, right? And if you go anywhere
above that, basically the user gets disengaged.
The goal for us is to render pages within
one second and preferably actually much faster,
right? We want a seamless experience for our
easers. That's something we care a lot about
at Google. This is great, right? We have this
research, but you might be something at this
point, that's great and all, but really does
it matter? Does it affect my site? The answer
is yes, it does. There are a number of case
studies out there. This was a case study done.
This was a joint research project between
Google and Bing. What we had done is we actually
slowed down -- intentionally slowed down our
search pages. The results that you are seeing
here are actually from Bing.com where they
added extra latency into their search pages.
They just measured, how does that impact the
use behavior on the site. Do they click more
or less and other things, right? What you
can see is basically there's a lot of red.
There's a lot of negative signs, and when
the add 2,000 milliseconds, two seconds, the
per-user dropped by 4.3%, which is, of course,
a huge number for a big site like Bing and
Google search. Now, this is not only applicable
to large sites, like search sites, but also
across the web in general. This is a great
case study done by [indiscernible] which looked
at 160 large e-commerce sites. What they found
was that adding one second of extra delay
decreased the user conversions. 7%. Fewer
page views and obviously the customer satisfaction
also dropped quite dramatically. So very quickly
this translates into real dollar. This is
not just dollars and cents, this is millions
of dollars for many large sites. And I think
you'll find this is true for your site as
well. So out of that, of course, we have the
web performance optimization industry, or
WPO industry if you have been following the
space. The basic premise of the WPO industry
is we have this waterfall graph. We are using
a lot of requests, 86 requests an average,
for an average page, over one megabyte. What
can we do to this waterfall graph to make
everything look faster? Can we download less?
Can we execute the code faster? You heard
about the great improvements that we are doing
in JavaScript space and rendering performance
in Chrome. What else can we do as app developers?
The platform can advance, but we can do a
lot of things as developers to optimize this.
Of course, there are a lot of best practices
out there, a lot of good tips about how to
optimize this kind of thing. Great books by
Steve Seibers and others. We have techniques
that I think many of us already do in our
applications and things like image compression
resizing, minimizing assets, caching. The
laundry list goes on and on and on and the
question at this point, of course, great.
We have the industry. We have all the best
practices, so why isn't it that all the web
sites are fast by default? I think the answer
here is that a lot of these practices around
performance can actually slow you down in
other ways. For example, doing things like
image spreading means that you need to talk
to your designers and get them think about
image formats and invest in build tool chain
and a lot of these things, frankly, are hacked.
They slow us down. We want to build features,
we want to focus on features in our apps.
Not necessarily think about minute details
of should I concatenate these back and forth.
It's a trade-off,right. It's a feature. It's
a feature that requires a lot of investment.
It is not something you add at the end. You
don't build your app and at the end say, yeah,
we're going to do a performance print to clean
it up, right? That's how you get it wrong.
It needs to be part of your culture. It needs
to be part of the tool chain. So it's a continuous
process. So that's what PageSpeed is all about.
We do three things. PageSpeed tries to help
you identify what are the potential performance
problems currently on your site? Think of
it as a performance Linter for your application.
Second one is just explaining and providing
guidance for how do you address these problems.
The last one, which I think is the most exciting,
is the automation part. We can actually take
a way a lot of the day-to-day work that you
have to do and do it for you, which is great.
So the rest of this talk is split into two
parts. First we will look at the analysis
and then the optimization parts.
On the analysis part, we have a number of
different options that you should play with.
And each one is good in a different context.
We will cover each. And then there's a number
of optimization products. So we have a plug-ins
for your servers that you can install that
will automate a lot of these best practices.
Let's dive in. Let's start with the analysis
part and look at PageSpeed Insights. PageSpeed
Insights is an extension that you can install
in Google Chrome. Go need to go to the Chrome
store, search for PageSpeed Insights. You
will get a new panel in your DevTools that
will give you a lot of nice performance tips.
Let's actually do a live demo. I was getting
a little hungry earlier today. Looking at
redrobin.com, beautiful site, beautiful images.
Nice little gallery here. Let's open up DevTools.
I have the PageSpeed insights extension installed.
I should click here. I can click analyze.
What it will do, it will reload the page.
It will basically monitor all the network
traffic, all of the assets that you're specifying
on the page and run a number different rules
against them and checks against them. So you
can see, great, here's our report. This page
got a score of 49 out of 100. That immediately
tells me there's room for improvement. The
real interesting stuff is actually here on
the left. So if you pay attention here, right,
we basically prioritize a lot of recommendations
on the left saying there's some high priority
things you can take care of right now to help
optimize your page and then there's other
stuff. Let's start at the top. Optimize images.
It turns out this Red Robin page is actually
about 10 megabytes in size every time you
load it. So -- and we will come back to why
"every time you load it." By optimizing images,
it turns out that red Robin is actually using
PNG images for the beautiful gallery. By just
converting that to a jpeg or a webp, as you
heard during the keynote, we can save 50%
of the bytes sent for this page. We can reduce
the total size of the page is 4.7 megabytes.
This is a huge amount. Think of the difference
this will make both in speed on desktop and
on mobile. One cool little tip that I like
to share PageSpeed insights, how do we know
that we can save all this data? What PageSpeed
insights does is it takes the images and actually
optimizes it when you run the analysis. It
can give you the optimized assets. So you
have this original picture here, right? We
can click on this guy. If I can go back, I
click on see optimize content. This is the
optimized version. Can you guys see the difference
between the two? It's a lot smaller. Right?
It's about 1.5 megabytes smaller. Right there
and then, you can right click on that image
and save it into your application and be done
with it. Right? Step number one, optimizing
images. Then you continue going down the list.
Things like browser caching. So it turns out
we analyzed all of the assets. This site is
not specifying cache control headers. Every
time you visit the page, you have refetch
all of the CSS, JavaScript and the images.
Instead we should be able to cache on a client.
So very simple thing to fix. If you are not
sure what this actually means or how to do
this, click on learn more, it will take you
to the documentation slide to explain that.
Enabling compression, so it turns out -- we
talked about images compression. But for text-based
assets, things like JavaScript and CSS, the
site also doesn't have JSUP enabled. There's
a lot of savings we can get here. We also
found that there's a lot of small images.
You can put this into a Sprite. You can minimize
JavaScript to get more performance. You can
see how just going through this list, this
is your performance Linter. You can run this
against any web site, your own site, locally
or elsewhere.
So really, really nice tool. This is effectively
when we just went through. That's the PageSpeed
extension. You can install it, run it against
any app locally or remote. That's great. We
also provide the web tools. If you are just
curious to play with it, you can go to our
developers.google.com/speed site. You can
type in any website and we will run all the
same rules against that site and give you
a report card. As you can see here, it all
looks the same. All the same high priority
recommendations. That's because it's the same
code running under the hood. But great way
to capture this. I can send this to my buddies
and say, hey, we've got a performance problem.
We have to address it. If nothing else, a
great way to play with it.
And finally we also have the PageSpeed insights
API. This is great if you really want to take
it to the next level. So now you have some
built infrastructure, you're checking in code,
you have continues builds kicking off every
time you check in code. You can actually script
this and use our PageSpeed rule engine to
run a number of checks against your code or
against your site periodically and basically
build a performance report. We have things
like -- you can specify strategy. So you can
say, I want to evaluate the rules against
desktop site and mobile site. We have slightly
different rule sets for mobile, for obvious
reasons, right? It's a very different environment.
I want to check for a specific type of rule.
For example, I want to make sure all the images
optimized. There's a lot of fine grain control.
And a lot of tools are integrating or using
PageSpeed Insights API to pull in that extra
meta data. This is a regular Google API. There's
no extra quirks to it. This is just a quick
example in ruby. Really, really handy. So
that's a very quickly an overview of what
you can do by just leveraging PageSpeed to
find performance problems, right? PageSpeed
insights gives you that hands on look. You
can use the web or the native version. And
then you can use the API to script this stuff
and automate a lot of this work.
Now, we built a rule engine that can scan
your pages. It can track what things you should
do. Can't we just do it for you? Like we have
already given you all of this practices. Giving
you the images. Let's go one step further,
right? That's what PageSpeed Optimization
is all about. So we have this core project,
an open source project that can be leveraged
as part of any web server called PageSpeed
Optimization Libraries. It's basically a set
of C++ classes that takes in some input, say
a style sheet or an image file or something
else, and then optimizes that based on a number
of criteria. So how does this actually look?
The way I think about PageSpeed Optimization
is as a performance jit for your site. Just
like V8 takes your JavaScript and does all
kinds of crazy optimizations to make it run
fast, that's what we do on the server except
we are rewriting and optimizing your JavaScript
CSS images and html. All of that is automated
for you. So you don't have to change your
application. I think that's the real exciting
part. We have a ton of sites, over 400,000
sites using PageSpeed today already and there
is a lot of different filters that will do
this work. So let's take a look at what it
actually does. At a very high level, I have
intentionally made these graphs really, really
tiny. The point is not to focus on what are
each of the assets. But basically, once you
turn on PageSpeed this is hopefully what you
see. We try to reduce the number of requests
by concatenating files and applying all the
best practices. It's a better experience for
the user.
So once again, the cool thing about this is
you don't have to modify your application.
We are not talking about adding more build
steps. This is not something that you run
on a check-in and it mangles your code and
rewrites your code. You don't have to bug
your designer buddies to say, hey, you should
pay attention to image compression because
all this is done on the server. This is especially
awesome for things like user-generated content.
It's one thing for us as developers to build
really optimized sites. Then we hand over
the keys to our awesome, fast-performing sites
to our users. They grab their awesome 50 megapixel
or something camera, snap a couple photos
of kittens, throw up the 80 MEG version on
the web, there you are, right, downloading
these high res images. We can automate that
for you.
So here's an example, right?
This is all really abstract. Let's take a
look at a real example. Let's say you have
some code like the one at the top here. So
we have four different style sheets: yellow,
blue, big, and bold. So we know that one of
the best practices is we want to concatenate
files to reduce the number of requests, such
that it downloads faster.
What PageSpeed will do is it will actually
look at the HTML when the server is serving
that HTML and it will actually rewrite all
of those into this command at the bottom.
And basically this is like a -- this tells
us the exact thing that we need to do to reconstruct
the entire asset, right? You can kind of decipher
it. It basically says "I want you to combine
yellow with blue with big with bold." Dot
PageSpeed is just our extension that says
to our module that "Hey, you should intercept
it in the future." "cc" stands for combined
CSS. And then we provide a fingerprint. And
the fingerprint is important, because when
you change later the contents of any one of
these files and say blue.CSS, you don't want
to think about like do I need to revalidate
the cache, how does this even work with PageSpeed.
We do all of that for you. We fingerprint
each file such that the moment you change
it we automatically rev the version of the
file. You don't need to think about that.
There's no extra build steps there.
And the other cool thing is because we're
fingerprinting this entire file, we can cache-extend
it for a year, right? This plays really, really
nicely with CDNs and all of your caches that
you're running. Squid, Varnish, and other
things.
So that's kind of a cute example with CSS.
I think a more interesting one is images,
because images as we said is 60% of the bytes,
so what can we do there?
Well, let's take a look at this example. We
have an image which is an awesome cat image
and we want to display it at 800 pixels wide,
right?
Now, this is a PNG file and we know that PNGs
are not good for photos, right? They're not
the most efficient format for serving photos,
so that's already kind of a tipoff. Well,
what PageSpeed will do is it will in the background
take this PNG file which is right now 350
kilobytes and it will try to recompress it
using other codecs. So JPEG and WebP. And
it will kind of stash those in the background,
right? So think of it as a background thread
just optimizing these images for you. We haven't
done anything yet.
Then a request comes to a server, and PageSpeed
will actually run a user agent check to say,
"Okay, this is a Chrome browser. Chrome understands
WebP, which means I can serve it a WebP file,"
versus, "Hey, this is an IE user coming, you
know, an older client coming to my site. They
don't understand WebP so I'll serve a JPEG,"
right?
And all of that is completely transparent
to the user and to your application. This
is done by the server.
Then the next thing that we do is we're actually
much smarter than that. We look at the markup
and we notice that you said you want this
image to be 800 pixels wide, right?
We look at the image that's actually on disk
that you've given us and we say is it 800
pixels wide or are you shipping the -- you
know, the large image and resizing it on the
client?
Well, turns out because this is an awesome
cat picture, he's 8,000 pixels wide, right?
So you would ship the large version, resize
it on the client. Instead, we will resize
it on the server and serve the right image.
So in the end, what PageSpeed will put in
your markup is kind of this cryptic URL at
the bottom which actually is not that cryptic
once you understand what it does. It's encoding
the size of the image, the name.PageSpeed.image
conversion and once again that half. So if
you change your version, we'll just run the
version.
And this basically automates the entire workflow.
We went from PNG to serving a dynamic WebP
file, right? From 350 kilobytes to 60 kilobytes.
And your application hasn't changed. Which
I think is the best part.
So those are just two examples. We have over
40 different optimization filters as part
of PageSpeed. We can do things like rewriting
JavaScript, combining JavaScript. We can defer
JavaScript. So we find that a lot of pages
have blocking, CSS, and JavaScript files which
are blocking rendering. For example, social
widgets and all the rest. Which we can safely
defer until later such that the page paints
and then we add the extra functionality, things
like social widgets and other things.
Simple things -- or actually they're not simple.
Things like lazy loading of images, right?
How many people here have tried doing lazy
loading of images.
[ Show of hands ]
>>Ilya Grigorik: Right? It's a pain in the
butt, right? It's like which library do I
use and how do I detect the unscroll event?
When do I know it's in my viewport? We take
care of all of that, right? You basically
set one command line flag in your config and
we just do all of that work for you.
So one thing to note is, of course, you know,
this doesn't come for free, necessarily, so
this runs on your server, and it does consume
some extra cycles. But all the optimizations
are done on demand. So for example, you come
and visit my gallery page. We will optimize
the images in the background. Our goal is
to make your site fast and sometimes optimizing
images may take a while, right? Like it may
take a couple hundred milliseconds. We're
not going to slow down your site. On the first
hit, we may actually serve the original image
because we don't want to block the client,
but on a subsequent visit, we will serve the
optimized assets and you guys will see this
in a second.
So the very cool thing about PageSpeed is,
of course, it's an open source project and
we have modules for Apache, Nginx, and we
have a Google hosted version which means that
we've had a lot of partners that have adopted
PageSpeed. And for example, DreamHost, GoDaddy,
and a number of other hosting providers basically
offer it as a toggle button for your Web site,
right?
You literally go into the control panel and,
just like it says, make my site fast. And
that's what it does. It enables PageSpeed
under the hood.
We have CDNs, large CDNs that are deploying
this technology at the edge, such that they
can revalidate your assets on the fly for
you. And of course we're DogFooding it at
Google as well.
Earlier today at the keynote, you guys saw
Linus talk about Chrome data compression,
so the way that works is your phone connects
to a Google server when you send the request,
and then it's the Google servers that fetch
the content that you requested, we optimize
it, and serve you the optimized version, right?
Which gives us a huge savings in data compression
and other things.
And the core of that is actually powered by
a lot of the PageSpeed logic that we've been
just talking about here, so we're reusing
that same technology to drive Chrome data
compression.
And 50% data compression is a huge win for
a lot of users. Bytes are literally expensive
for a lot of people, right?
You can be charged as high as a dollar per
megabyte when you're roaming, so this stuff
adds up really quickly.
So if you guys haven't tried it yet, I'd definitely
encourage you to. Go and download Chrome beta
from the apps store and go into your settings
and enable this and I think you'll notice
that your pages load much, much faster.
Which is yet more motivation to -- for why
you need to optimize your pages.
This is a great case study. AOL is rolling
out mod_pagespeed which is our Apache plug-in
for PageSpeed, and they're deploying it on
a number of sites. These are the two most
recent ones, both very high traffic sites.
They enabled PageSpeed and they immediately
got 40% and 20% Page Load Time improvement
by just enabling PageSpeed, right? So no applications
changes. Everything is done by the Apache
server. Nice win.
We've been working with ZippyKid, which is
a great hosting provider for Wordpress and
really focused on performance. We ran a number
of tests, so they're actually using the Nginx
plugin for their servers, and they found that,
you know, they're getting a speedup of over
50% and a huge reduction in savings.
So it turns out that Wordpress sites are very
media heavy. Surprise, right? Like that's
-- that shouldn't be a surprise.
And you can see results like the one on the
-- on the left here where the original site
was over 7 megabytes in size. Once we ran
the image optimization and other kind of best
practices, we're down to -- let's see -- 1
megabyte and a little bit more, right? 1.4
megabytes.
So huge, huge savings.
So how do you get started?
The best place is actually to just go to mod_pagespeed.com
or Nginx_PageSpeed. I think those are -- those
are two of the most popular servers out there.
It's open source. You can grab it. You can
play with it. We provide the packaging for
it. You can basically grab the RPM and install
it and also a shout-out to a couple of community-developed
modules. So if you're using IIS server, you
can actually also use PageSpeed. There's a
great new project called IIS Speed that's
being developed and gives you the same functionality
within IIS. And also, the guys at LinkedIn
are running PageSpeed and they're using Apache
traffic server, so they're the ones developing
the Apache traffic server module, which I
think is really cool.
So we're all building off the same core and
continuing to improve this infrastructure.
So this is great, right? Like I have my Web
server. I can install this module. I can configure
it. I can do other things.
But there's still more that I can do. I can
still deploy my assets to a CDN. I want to
have some protection against denial of service
attacks. And a number of other features. Wouldn't
it be nice if somebody did all of this work
for you?
And that, in effect, is what PageSpeed service
is.
So this is a beta product and project that
we have at Google today. You can sign up for
it. It's currently in beta. And the way it
works is, the traffic to your site is routed
through Google servers.
So, you know, if you want to get technical,
you create -- you cname your www domain to
point to Google servers, such that when users
type in, you know, www your site dot com,
they actually hit a Google server. The Google
server then goes to your server and requests
the actual content. It grabs that content,
does all of the optimization, saves all of
the optimized assets in the Google cloud,
in the Google CDN, and, you know, we have
a few servers around the world to do that
kind of thing, and serves the optimized assets.
So you're getting the benefit of CDN and dynamic
optimization, which is really, really cool.
So I actually have it running on my site and
I want to show you guys a demo of how this
works in practice.
So here I am. Here's my site. I have this
beautiful little gallery of, you know, my
favorite travel photos. I -- I love them in
all of their high-res glory because I'm a
photographer and I would never think about,
you know, doing anything less, but I think
we can do a lot better, right? So if you go
to the network tab and if we just sort the
file size on the page, you can see that there's
three images, Tokyo, Oxford, and Aurora, weighing
in at about 3 megabytes and they're served
as PNG files. That's how I saved them as.
I think we can do better.
So I have PageSpeed service running on my
site. If I go to my Google API console, I'm
looking at the PageSpeed service tab here.
Let's go to "Overview." So basically what's
happening here is here's my origin server,
PageSpeed server, so the Google servers are
in between, and if we go to configure rewriters,
this is where all of the magic happens, right?
We -- we basically have a set of check boxes
and let me make that a little bit bigger.
Oops, that's not blowing up.
We have a set of check boxes that just allow
you to apply optimizations without actually
modifying your app. So for example, I'm concerned
about images, so let's go into optimize images
and I want to do a few things.
So I want to resize images on the server,
such that if I'm serving a file size of -- or
an image that is larger than what I meant
to display, just optimize it for me.
And also convert PNG files to JPEG.
That sounds about like what I want, right?
I'm serving PNGs so let me save that.
I'm going to apply this to the live site and
we're going to refresh the site.
And we're actually going to do this twice.
And the reason we do this twice is remember
what I said earlier, we don't want to slow
down the site? So the first time we may server
the unoptimized asset or the original asset,
but then on the next load, you can see that
the filename has changed. It now has this
PageSpeed URL and now it's being served as
a JPEG. So what PageSpeed service has done
-- notice that I haven't -- like I haven't
done anything on my site, right? The Google
cloud is handling all of this. It's rewritten
the image, it's fingerprinted the image, and
it's serving a JPEG, and the images, they're
the same size. That's not good. There we go.
That was just a caching error. So a hundred
kilobytes versus one megabyte, right? But
I think we can do better, right? So right
now, our image -- our total size of this page
is 467 kilobytes so let's go back to the console
and also enable convert JPEG to WebP and -- sure,
let's just enable it all. Why not. And apply
to live. And we're going to do the same test
again so we'll refresh it again.
Now, Chrome, of course, understands WebP,
so in theory we should see WebP images coming
through once they're optimized, and there
they are. So we have the WebP -- let's just
re-share -- resort here.
So we have the Tokyo file. It's now at 81
kilobytes. Previously it was 120. And the
total size of the page is 328 kilobytes. So
we went from a page that's over 3 megabytes
to 328 kilobytes. That's a 10X improvement,
right? And I didn't have to modify my application.
The images are rescaled on the server and
served in the best possible format.
If we were to open this in IE, it would just
serve a JPEG. I don't have to worry about
that.
So that's pretty awesome.
Now, this works, of course, for any site that
you host on, you know, any hosting provider.
You just need to cname your site. But if you're
using AppEngine, you can also take advantage
of Google PageSpeed service.
What you need to do -- and unfortunately it's
a little bit small here -- you can modify
your app.yaml file, and you have good documentation
how to do this, and you can just specify which
filters you want PageSpeed service to apply.
And before the request gets routed to your
application server, it will actually be processed
by our PageSpeed service proxy and it will
do all this work for you.
So we ran this experiment on HTML5 Rocks.
I'm sure you guys have seen the site. If not,
I encourage you to. Lots of great material.
It's actually an AppEngine app. It's a Python
AppEngine app. It's open source. You can actually
check it out on Github and you can check the
exact modules and optimizations we're applying.
So we used Google Analytics to run an experiment
and say what happens if we enable PageSpeed
service and then disable it? So we ran an
A/B test, and, you know, we added six or seven
lines, whatever it is, to our app.yaml file
and we made our site 10% faster. This is as
measured by Page Load Time, right? And there's
another -- a number of other metrics which
we've improved as well.
So this is a huge, huge win.
Especially for seven lines of modifications.
So I think the takeaway here is automating
Web performance best practices offers a lot
of benefits. First of all, performance is
a continuous process, it's not a checklist
item, it's not something that you add at the
end. Right? So building or leveraging these
automated tools allows us to just not worry
about that.
The other thing is, we just don't have to
worry about things anymore, a lot of things
anymore. So for example, when I save my images
on my own site, I just save them as whatever
format I'm working with, right? Like I'll
save them as a PNG. I don't have to think
about what is the optimal format for this
image. I'll let the computer or the servers
figure that out for me. I can just go into
my control panel and kind of fiddle with the
quality of what goes in and other things.
Not only that but I can also dynamically adjust
the quality based on the client, right? Maybe
for a mobile site, you want to serve slightly
lower quality images because the screens are
smaller, and frankly, the users won't notice,
but that's a huge byte savings that you could
have.
These kinds of things you can't do manually,
right? How do you implement that in your application?
You would have to do -- use JavaScript with,
you know, detection of the client. It's a
mess, right?
Let the server handle that for you.
Not only that, but we can do dynamic optimizations
that you can't, frankly, do manually, right?
So you saw us serving WebP files. That would
be a disaster to build into your application,
right? It's doable but it's hard.
And then there's things like work on HTTP
2.0 and SPDY, so our SPDY protocol is now
being standardized as HTTP 2.0 and they're
adding a lot of great new improvements to
it, and frankly, it's going to address a lot
of the problems that we have to deal with
today. Things like concatenating files? We
don't have to do that anymore with HTTP 2.0.
Right? So now that all of you guys have concatenated
all of your files, please go ahead and undo
all of that, because that's what you do to
improve performance on HTTP 2.0, right? But
then how do you serve the optimized version
for both, right? Because HTTP 2.0 is not going
to come overnight. It will take a while. And
this is where automation can come in. This
is where the server can automatically decide
and figure out like, "Hey, you're an HTTP
2.0 client. I just won't do this class of
optimizations for you," right? So this is
a great reason to invest into this -- into
these kinds of tools. And frankly, at the
end of the day it just allows you to focus
on your application. So with that, we have
a little bit of time for questions, and if
you guys can, please grab one of the mics.
>>> Thank you. This is really awesome.
Two questions. Firstly, retina images. Any
thoughts on that?
>>Ilya Grigorik: Yeah. So retina images is
a big discussion, I think, in the web community
today. We're looking at a couple of solutions
for serving high DPI images, like 2X images.
We don't have any built-in filters today,
but we have some in the works, and right now,
I guess the problem is we don't have a generic
way to do that across browsers.
>>> Okay. And sorry, the second one, the service
looks even better. Is that something you expect
to be a paid service when it comes out of
beta?
>>Ilya Grigorik: PageSpeed? Right. So PageSpeed
service is in beta right now. It is free while
it's in beta and we are still trying to determine
what is the right module to actually, you
know, charge for it and all the rest. Because
it is being served through the Google cloud
and, you know, there's -- there may be some
additional fee in the future,
But I don't think we have a good answer yet.
Yeah.
>>> Thank you.
>>> Can PageSpeed help you if you use a single-page
Web app who loads its content using Ajax?
>>Ilya Grigorik: Yeah, so can PageSpeed help
us with single-page apps? Perhaps not as much,
right, because you are probably doing a lot
of the loading through JavaScript over your
assets and all the rest. But you can -- if
you leverage things like just regular image
tags and other things, you can configure PageSpeed
to do transparent rewriting and optimization
of images.
I showed you examples where you rewrite the
URL. You can actually configure it the other
way around such that the image is -- the URL
is the same and then still leverage some of
the functionality.
>>> All right. Thank you.
>>> Let me interrupt you. Sorry. So as a Rails
developer, are there any caveats that we have
to worry about when developing more dynamic
apps? Is this suitable for just sort of static
pages? Or what's the -- or what do we need
to know about using PageSpeed for dynamic
things?
>>Ilya Grigorik: I don't think there are any
constraints whether it is a static app or
a dynamic app. It really doesn't matter.
So the way PageSpeed works, it basically intercepts
your request at the very end before it gets
served by the server. So it doesn't matter
who generated.
For Rails specifically, Rails, of course,
has asset pipeline and other things that try
to do a lot of this work at deploy time, right,
concatenating files and all the rest.
I would actually say you don't need to do
that anymore. You don't have to worry about
it. PageSpeed will do all of that for you,
plus more, because we can do dynamic optimizations.
>>> So quick question. With the beta that
you have running, is there an upper limit
on the number of assets that we could have
cached if I want to do A/B testing for my
company?
>>Ilya Grigorik: No, there's no limit on that.
>>> Okay. And just to sort of -- to tag onto
the previous gentleman's question, how would
PageSpeed handle something, like I said, of
using RequireJS or something where we're sort
of doing, like, lazy load of static assets?
>>Ilya Grigorik: Yeah. So we have our own
filters that do, for example, defer JavaScript,
right, which will grab your code and actually
wrap it in our own kind of markup to defer
it to load later.
So RequireJS is effectively that, but you
are doing it manually.
We don't have -- and it would be very hard
to build scripts that introspect into RequireJS.
So we may not be able to as much if you are
doing this kind of dynamic construction of
the page.
But that's really an area that we are looking
for feedback from you guys as well because,
you know, I think these are -- these are the
new apps that are being built. So if there
is more interest in that, we'll start looking
in that direction.
>>> Thank you.
>>> I actually have three questions. One is
can we use this with sites that have SSL enabled?
I wouldn't be comfortable giving Google my
SSL certificate.
>>Ilya Grigorik: Yeah, so for SSL, the answer
is yes. Basically, you would determine your
SSL at your server, right? So, okay, there
is a couple, I guess, questions.
Open source or PageSpeed service?
>>> The PageSpeed service.
>>Ilya Grigorik: For PageSpeed service, you
would have to upload your certificates to
one of our servers, so I have it set up on
my site. You can actually try it. I upload
the certificate and the connection is terminated
at the Google server.
>>> Okay. The second question I had was how
much of an additional load in terms of CPU
and memory does PageSpeed module add onto
Apache or Nginx?
>>Ilya Grigorik: That's a great question.
For example, it can take a while, right, hundreds
of milliseconds to do.
So I think it is giving me the boot.
So what we do is we actually give you knobs
to control how much resources you are willing
to give the server. So, for example, you can
tweak the number of threads that we will employ
in the background to optimize the stuff. You
can also tweak the size of our cache. For
multi-server deployments, we actually provide
mem cache -- caching. Instead of storing the
optimized assets on just one server, you can
share it across a cluster of servers.
So there is a lot of knobs. I didn't cover
these here. There is a lot of great documentation
that we have on our site that you can look
into.
>>> Can we extend the PageSpeed module with
additional filters?
>>Ilya Grigorik: Can you say that again, sorry?
>>> Can we extend the module with additional
filters, if you want to write out custom filters
to do some optimizations?
>>Ilya Grigorik: Oh, sure, yeah. It is an
open source project. Actually, the guy standing
behind you is the guy to talk to.
You can contribute new filters. We would love
your participation. If you want to, we have
a very active mod PageSpeed discussion group.
Just ping us there and we are happy to talk
about it.
>>> Thank you.
>>> Hi. So a lot of applications these days
are written using clientside templating frameworks
like Ember, Angular, Backbone. How does this
play with serving up static templates and
any of the --
>>Ilya Grigorik: So, the short answer is I
don't think we have a good answer for that
today. We are basically -- we rely on being
able to analyze your HTML, your markup, plus
the JavaScript and CSS assets. We discover
those in part through analyzing your HTML.
So there may not be as much that we can do
there.
You can configure the server as I mentioned
earlier to do transparent rewriting of images
and a few other things.
But I think that's an area that we can definitely
do more in, in the future.
>>> Hi. I'm Josh,(saying name). I work on
the PageSpeed optimization project. I wanted
to point out that actually just to this point
and the one made earlier, if you have -- if
you are loading assets via JavaScript, we
do a pretty good job of optimizing them.
What we don't know is the sizing context because
we just get to -- we get a request for a JPEG
file and we optimize that based on whatever
the user agent is. We don't know how big it
was supposed to -- what slot it was supposed
to go in. And we can't change its cache lifetime
if we can't change its URL.
>>Ilya Grigorik: Yep.
>>> But the on-the-fly transcoding that you
get for reducing image size and bandwidth
for Android browsers that uses that flow.
>>Ilya Grigorik: One note to that. As you
guys probably have noticed, we have a performance
area in the Chrome booth section. And we have
a big contingent from the PageSpeed family
of products hanging out there. If you guys
want to talk to us about specific questions,
how to implement stuff or just have ideas,
please drop by.
>>> Yeah. That's just about Java. You showed
us how to implement that on that page using
Python. Do you have any examples in Java?
And you showed us the URL to get to the beta.
If you could share with us these slides or
go back to the URL?
>>Ilya Grigorik: I will take the last one
first. So if you just use your favorite search
engine and look for PageSpeed service, you
will land directly on the link that you need.
That's the simplest way to get there. And
then the other one was -- question was Java
versus Python examples.
>>> Yeah, you showed us the Python example
and how to do that on yaml file.
>>Ilya Grigorik: Oh, sure. Yeah, the great
thing about PageSpeed service is, it is completely
agnostic of the runtime that you are using.
There is no difference between Java, Python,
and all the rest.
If you go to the Google AppEngine documentation
and just search for PageSpeed, you will have
the specific commands that you need in there.
>>> Awesome. Thank you.
>>Ilya Grigorik: Yep.
>>> Thank you. Hi. I have been using PageSpeed
service for a while and it is pretty impressive.
And I have one question, is that you mentioned
you deployed several servers and words to
get -- to make the optimization.
>>Ilya Grigorik: Yeah.
>>> So we know in order to make the optimization,
you need to make several subsequent -- subrequests
of the first requests. So I was wondering,
can you share a little bit about your global
deployment and the method you used to determine
the closest server for optimization.
>>Ilya Grigorik: So, thankfully, we actually
on PageSpeed service don't necessarily need
to do anything. This is part of the global
Google caching policy, right? Whenever you
issue a request to Google Search, we try to
determine what is the closest location. We
can do that through DNS, through I.P. lookups.
There is a variety of different methods. And
we just leverage all of that infrastructure
at PageSpeed.
So, basically, your site is getting deployed
on the same infrastructure that is powering
Google Search and other things, all right?
So picking the closest server to the user
is just part of the magic, if you will. It
is not something you need to configure at
all or worry about within your application.
>>> Thank you.
>>Ilya Grigorik: Yep.
>>> Are there any optimizations that are device-dependent?
So, for instance, having images that would
be more optimized for mobile devices versus
browsers?
>>Ilya Grigorik: The answer is absolutely
yes. The best one is the WebP example I shared.
Only certain user agents are able to use it.
Another example would be leveraging local
storage. So not all clients are able to leverage
local search, and we actually have a filter
that can use local storage as a cache for
your assets.
And we will deploy those optimizations conditionally.
And Josh is going to --
>>> Yeah, you can also say for small screens
compress more aggressively than for large
screens.
>>Ilya Grigorik: Yep, yep.
>>> So kind of a follow-up on that, both for
the service as well as for something like
mod PageSpeed, how is the universe of user
agents that are being identified to optimize
for being managed and the frequency with which
it gets updated?
>>Ilya Grigorik: So we -- Right. So we test
the stuff very extensively. All the code is
open source.
Josh, do you want to share any details? I
think -- so one thing I didn't mention, I
had in those slides, we have two sets of filters,
COR and optional filters. COR filters are
the safe filters. They should be -- can be
applied to any site without any risk or minimal
risk on the site in terms of modifying the
look and feel.
And then there's an extended list of other
optimizations which we can do on a per-user-agent
basis and the rest.
>>> So in the open source world, we have to
kind of cut releases and ship product. So
we have -- we take kind of a white-listing
view of what we can do for different browsers.
So if you are using mod PageSpeed from last
month and this month there is a new device
that can support WebP, we won't know about
it.
>>Ilya Grigorik: Back in November of last
year, we shipped the 1.0 of mod PageSpeed.
And when we did that switch, we are shipping
two channels. There is a beta channel, and
there is a stable channel, very similar to
Chrome.
If you want to be on the edge and try all
the latest optimizations that's where you
would be. If you are a little bit more nervous
about how this will work across all the devices,
you should stick with the stable channel.
>>> Another question is, all this is awesome
to have it happen Automagically. When it does
that, does it also output reports so you can
go back to your developers and say: Hey, you
should code better and this is how.
>>Ilya Grigorik: That's PageSpeed insights.
We are effectively taking that same engine,
or the same rules and just automating all
of that for you.
>>> Does it output of what it's actually done
so you can go back without having to run it
through insights on its own? Do you get some
logging of, Hey, we did these concatenations
aside from the image optimization.
>>Ilya Grigorik: That's interesting. I don't
think we actually -- we do have a statistics
screen where we can go and kind of gather
some data about what is a server doing. How
is it doing to tune its performance? We don't
have an audit log today to say, like, these
are the explanations we have performed.
>>> Okay. Thank you.
>>> I realize we are wrapping up. I will go
quick. Is there any danger zones, things you
should not use -- not do -- not -- if you
are using this, you should probably not use
PageSpeed on your server if, we are using
open source Apache and Nginx models?
>>Ilya Grigorik: Sorry, can you --
>>> Talking too fast. If I'm doing X, then
is there something that I -- should I not
in this case use PageSpeed?
>>Ilya Grigorik: Oh, I see. No. So coming
back to COR filters, the safe filters, we
try to be careful about what kind of optimizations,
rewriting, we do to your markup, JavaScript
and CSS.
I would actually say once you have PageSpeed
in place, you can undo a lot of the stuff
that you're doing. So it probably makes sense
just from simplifying your workflow, not having
to work about a bunch of things.
If you stick with the COR filters, you should
be pretty safe. But please test first.
One thing I didn't mention and I should have,
a really great tip, if you go to webpagetest.org/compare,
you can type in your site and it will run
it through PageSpeed service and it will give
you a side-by-side comparison.
If you enabled this thing, what would you
get? So in the -- in our documentation, we
provide a lot of toggles to selectively enable
specific filters. Like, you can pass us a
query parameter string to say, I'm curious
what is going to happen if I enable image
lazy loading. And you can do that on a per-request
basis such that as a developer, you can test
one of these optimizations and then decide
whether you want to make that part of your
COR configuration.
All right. Thanks, guys. If you have more
questions, as I mentioned, please come by
our Chrome area and ask us.
[ Applause ]